Maj Toure wants you armed, trained,
and ready to make peace.
If you are not fighting to defend
life, that's in imminent danger.
Your life, liberty or pursuit of
happiness and property.
Right?
You probably shouldn't be fighting.
Toure, a Philadelphia native, runs
the Solutionary Center in the
neighborhood of North Philly, a
place for locals to learn firearms,
skills, and safety to avoid
and de-escalate conflicts and
to pick up other life skills,
including first aid, yoga,
and phlebotomy.
We hear a lot of people say
if your communities if these
communities would just pull
themselves up by the bootstraps.
Okay. This is the Bootstrap.
Toure is a hardcore Libertarian,
founder of the gun rights group
Black Guns Matter and supporter
of the Mises Caucus that recently
took control of the Libertarian
Party.
From Philadelphia, Pennsylvania, Maj
Toure.
He told us that Libertarians can
improve their outreach in urban
America by getting behind
spokespeople with deep connections
to the people living there and an
intuitive understanding of their
needs and concerns.
People like him.
Reason sat down with Toure for
a wide-ranging
conversation about guns, liberty,
crime, and justice.
You pick a day, I'm going to give
you my direct number.
We use the space for free and a no
charge.
No doubt.
I appreciate you.
Same here.
So we're sitting here together,
the SolutionaryCenter in
Philadelphia.
Tell me about what happens here.
A little bit of everything.
We you can't say you want to do
community development and not have a
plan to develop the community.
And a lot of times I get it in this
Internet age, we do
a lot of things remote.
Can't teach you how to sell
remotely.
I mean, you probably could learn
some stuff, but hands on direction,
you know, when you're talking about
the communities that are impacted by
all of this silly shit.
That we see.
You got to be hands on.
Or it helps to be more hands on.
So the solution I send out, we do
conflict resolution, de-escalation,
firearms training, Spanish,
phlebotomy.
We got plumbing coming.
You know, anything that
you know, we hear a lot of people
say, if your
communities if these communities
would just pull themselves up by the
bootstraps, okay, this is the
bootstraps.
You know, and then the irony is,
after you start doing stuff like
this, I'm just waiting to get called
like a racist.
And waiting and I'm waiting to be
called like, oh, it's not inclusive
enough when I'm just doing the
stuff.
But, you know, hopefully we'll get
that popular to get hate it on that
with you know I'm saying but
that's what we do with the center
man. We are a a location
that if you can teach
something and you want to teach a
free class the spaces
available to you.
If you want to learn something and
you don't know if we have the
class there yet, you can.
Hey, we're interested in this.
Can you set up a class for that?
And everything's free here.
All of the money that we've raised
over how many years we've given it
away. And that's not just, you
know, the Solutionary Center, but
also, you know, with black guns
Matter, we want to remove the
financial barrier entry.
And if we can do this effectively
and efficiently in Philadelphia,
there's no reason that some of the
rich folks that's
going to watch this can't say, Hey,
I want you to do this in Chicago.
I want you to do this in Detroit.
And then we can franchise,
for lack of a better term, our
ability to solve problems, to
be solutions.
So yeah what is if you had to boil
down, like the mission statement
of the Solutionary Center like what
are you trying to accomplish?
Save the republic.
Oh, that's ambitious.
Yeah, yeah.
When you look at let's take the last
two years, right.
I am a, we are in a Democratic
city.
The Republican leadership
here does nothing.
The developers have done a
good job at developing, but they
have their own different interests.
And when you look at the
cities that are impacted the most
by the lack of liberty.
There's no answers
and they damn near lead the charge.
They damn near are the people
saying, this is how we're going to
do it. We're going to use the heavy
hand of the state.
To overreach into
your individual liberties.
And okay, if that if that actually
turned out not okay, but if that
actually turned out to be better for
cities, we would see it.
It's not the case.
When we started doing the work in
Black Guns Matter, we only did
conflict resolution and firearm
safety in Philadelphia that
year. I think it was 2016 when stats
came out.
Philly had the lowest violent crime
it had since like 1979.
There's something to be said there.
But just firearms ownership and
conflict resolution is not enough.
What are the skill sets that we can
give the community by the community
for the community to generate
better economics for themselves, to
generate a better social interaction
amongst the people, to generate a
reduction in crime.
Right. And there's going to be
spikes in everything.
However, this has to be the
solution. Now, why is that tie into
the overall mission of saving the
republic? All of the big cities that
have these problems, that
the politicians are horribly
uninformed about their actual job,
they're not presenting any
solutions.
We cannot rely on the state to solve
it. We literally the
people have to do it.
Individual donations, collective
work together all while respecting
the individual's rights.
When this becomes
super successful and in most
of the major cities, the people will
choose differently.
And if the people are choosing
differently and they're informed
about civics, the process, if
they're politically active, not just
every two or four years,
if they're socially empowered
and politically astute,
we save the republic.
If we do not,
I think people need to really
recognize that America cannot be
here the way that we're used to
would be. Mm hmm.
And if you're looking at the
inflation hype, that's not
even just hyperinflation damn near
stagflation.
If you look at these things now, we
are not going in a positive
direction.
We're not. Now, it's easy for me
to say, Well, that's the politicians
fault. And on one level, they
got to take accountability for that.
But what about the people
and their accountability, not just
for allowing it to happen,
but what are you going to do to
apply a solution so this doesn't
happen anymore?
So it is a lofty goal, but
it's doable.